si vous êtes les protecteurs de notre
univers l'avenir de l'académie dépend
véritablement de votre succès absolu tu
crois que quelqu'un a remarqué mon
arrivée est un des grand temps que tu
apprennes par les sons de la matière
highlander govou a amené nous les
méchants les skylanders bio on est là
pour ça mais il s'est juré
mais qu'est ce que tu m'as l'air de très
mauvaise humeur tu t'es levé du mauvais
côté du volcan swieten mauvaise humeur
là je le suis contrôleur plus féroce et
unième shanks 30 bling bling bling bling
jamais personne ne porte trop de bling
bling ou de mots
unissez vous
nouvelle série originale netfix
attendait mais le sol
le vrai green bird
j'ai rien compris à ce qu'il a dit ça
veut dire qu'ici c'est notre cible
n'auriez pas pu nous expliquer tout ça
sans faire ce cinéma l'académie
skylander school un nouvel équipier à
tête de bananes étaient comestibles
vas-y vas-y du calme pop